Quisiera comenzar diciendo: Houston, tenemos un problema.
Estamos entrando a una segunda generación sin progreso
en términos de vuelos espaciales tripulados. De hecho, hemos retrocecido.
Nos encontramos con una gran posibilidad de perder nuestra capacidad de inspirar a nuestros jóvenes
a ir fuera y continuar esto tan importante
que nosotros, como especie, siempre hemos hecho.
Y es que, instintivamente hemos ido fuera
y sobrepasado sitios dificultosos, ido a sitios más hostiles
para luego descubrir, posiblemente para nuestra sorpresa, que es por esa razón que hemos sobrevivido.
Y creo firmemente
que no es suficientemente bueno para nosotros tener generaciones de niños
que creen que está bien desear una versión mejorada
de un teléfono móvil con vídeo.
Ellos deberían desear la exploración, deberían pensar en colonización,
ellos deberían pensar en los avances. Ellos deben...
...tenemos que inspirarlos, porque es necesario que nos guíen
y nos ayuden a sobrevivir en el futuro.
Estoy particularmente preocupado por lo que la NASA está haciendo ahora con esta nueva doctrina "Bush"
de, para esta próxima década y media... oh rayos, la puse.
Aquí tenemos reglas específicas de no hablar de política.
(risas)
Lo que deseamos es...
(aplausos)
...lo que deseamos es
no solo inspirar a nuestros niños pequeños,
pero los planes actuales no están permitiendo siquiera
que la gente mas creativa de este país, los ingenieros aeroespaciales
de Boeing y Lockheed, tomen riesgos y prueben cosas nuevas.
Estaremos de vuelta a la luna... 50 años después,
y lo estamos haciendo de manera específicamente planeada para no aprender nada nuevo.
Estoy realmente preocupado por eso. Pero de todas formas --
la base de lo que quiero compartir con ustedes hoy, mas aún,
es regresar a donde inspiramos a aquellos
que van a ser nuestros grandes líderes del mañana.
Ese es el tema de mis próximos 15 minutos aquí.
Y creo que la inspiración empieza cuando uno es muy joven:
desde los 3 años, hasta los 12 - 14 años.
Lo que nosotros - lo que ellos miran es lo más importante.
Veamos el caso de la aviación,
donde hubo un corto período maravilloso de 4 años
en el que sucedieron cosas increíbles.
Comenzó en 1908, cuando los hermanos Wright volaron en París, y todo el mundo dijo:
"¡Ooh! ¡yo puedo hacer eso!" Muy poca gente voló
a comienzos de 1908. En cuatro años, 39 países tenían cientos de aeronaves,
miles de pilotos. Las aeronaves fueron inventadas por selección natural.
Ahora se puede decir que el diseño inteligente es quien diseña las aeronaves de hoy en día,
pero realmente no hubo diseño inteligente en el diseño de esas primeras aeronaves.
Se probaron - probablemente, 30.000 cosas distintas como mínimo,
y cuando ocurrían accidentes que matan al piloto..."no prueben eso de nuevo"
Los que volaron y aterrizaron bien
porque no había pilotos entrenados
quienes tenían buenas cualidades de vuelo, por definición.
Así que, haciendo un montón de intentos, miles de intentos,
en ese período de tiempo de cuatro años, inventamos los conceptos
de las aeronaves que volamos hoy en día. Y por eso son tan seguras,
porque dimos muchas oportunidades para encontrar lo que funciona bien.
Esto no ha sucedido en los vuelos espaciales.
Solo se han probado dos conceptos - dos por los E.E.U.U y uno por los Rusos.
Y bien, ¿quién ha sido inspirado durante ese tiempo?
Aviation Week me pidió hacerles una lista de quienes yo pensaba
que fueron los protagonistas de los primeros 100 años de aviación.
Y los escribí, descubriendo luego que cada uno de ellos
era un niño en ese maravilloso renacimiento de la aviación.
Bueno, lo que ocurrió cuando yo era un niño fueron cosas muy grandes también.
Comenzó la era de la propulsión, la era de los misiles. Von Braun estaba allí
mostrando como ir a Marte -- y esto fue antes del Sputnik.
Y eso fue en un momento en que Marte era muchísimo más interesante
de lo que es hoy en día. Pensábamos que habría animales allí,
sabíamos que había plantas, los colores cambian, ¿cierto?...
Pero ya saben, NASA arruinó todo eso porque mandaron estos robots
que han hecho aterrizar sólo en los desiertos.
(risas)
Si observan lo que sucedió -- esta pequeña línea negra es lo más rápido que el hombre ha volado jamás,
y la línea roja es el tope de la línea de aviones de caza militares,
y la línea azul son las aerolíneas comerciales.
Notan que existe un gran salto. Cuando yo era pequeño --
y creo que eso tuvo algo que ver con darme el valor
para salir e intentar algo que el resto de la gente no tenía valor para intentar.
Bueno, ¿qué hice cuando era pequeño?
No salia con chicas ni salía a bailar.
Y bueno, en esa época no había drogas. Pero si participé en competiciones de aeromodelismo.
Pasé unos siete años durante la guerra de Vietnam
como piloto de pruebas de aviones para la Fuerza Aérea.
Y luego empecé y me divertí mucho construyendo aeronaves
que las personas pudiesen construir en sus garajes.
Unos 3000 de esos están volando. Y claro, uno de ellos
es el Voyager, que dió la vuelta al mundo. Fundé otra compañía en 1982,
que es mi compañía actual.
Y hemos desarrollado más de un nuevo tipo de aeronave cada año desde 1982.
Y hay muchos de ellos que de hecho no puedo mostrarles en éstas láminas.
La aeronave más impresionante, yo creo, fue diseñada
solo 12 años después del primer jet funcional.
Estuvo en servicio hasta que se oxidó mucho como para volar y fué sacada de servicio.
Volvimos en 1998 de regreso a algo que se diseño en 1956. ¿Qué fué?
La nave espacial más impresionante, a mi parecer,
fue el Alunizador de Grumman. Fue un -- bueno, ustedes saben, llegó a la luna,
despegó de la luna, no necesitó a nadie de mantenimiento --
eso sí es impresionante.
Hemos perdido esa capacidad. La abandonamos en el '72
Esta cosa fue diseñada 3 años después del primer vuelo espacial de Gagarin en 1961.
3 años, y aun no podemos hacer eso hoy día.
Alocado. Hablemos brevemente de los ciclos de innovación, cosas que crecen,
tienen mucha actividad, y desaparecen cuando son reemplazadas por otra cosa.
Estas cosas tienden a suceder cada 25 años.
40 años, con algún arreglo. Pueden aplicar esa declaración
en todo tipo de tecnologías diferentes. Lo interesante es --
por cierto, la velocidad aquí, perdón, viajes de alta velocidad
es el título de estos ciclos de innovación. No hay ninguno aquí.
Estas dos nuevas aeronaves son de la misma velocidad que el DC8 que fue hecho en 1958.
Y aquí viene lo bueno, y es que uno no tiene ciclos de innovación
si el gobierno los desarrolla y el gobierno los usa.
Ustedes saben, un buen ejemplo, por supuesto, es la red DARPA.
Primero se usaron los ordenadores para artillería, luego para el IRS.
pero no fue hasta que los obtuvimos, que apareció todo el nivel de actividad,
todos nos beneficiamos de ello. El sector privado es el que tiene que hacerlo.
Mantengan eso en mente. Hablo de la innovación.
He buscado ciclos de innovación en el espacio, y no he encontrado ninguno.
En el primer año, empezando cuando Gagarin voló al espacio,
y Alan Shepherd unas cuantas semanas después, hubo 5 vuelos espaciales
tripulados en el mundo; tan solo el primer año.
En el 2003, todos los que EEUU mandó al espacio murieron.
Tan solo hubo 3 o 4 vuelos en el 2003.
En el 2004 hubo solamente 2 vuelos: 2 vuelos del Soyuz ruso
a la estación internacional tripulada. Y yo tuve que volar 3 en Mojave
con mi pequeño grupo de un par de docenas de personas
para poder completar un total de 5,
que fue el mismo número de aquel 1961.
No hay crecimiento. No hay actividad. No hay nada.
Esta es una imagen tomada desde el SpaceShipOne.
Esta es una imagen tomada desde órbita.
Nuestra meta es hacer que puedan ver esta imagen y de verdad disfrutarlo.
Sabemos como hacer el vuelo sub-orbital seguro, suficientemente seguro,
al menos tan seguro como las primeras aerolíneas lo eran.
Y creo que quiero hablar un poco acerca del por qué tuvimos el valor
de salir e intentarlo como una pequeña compañia.
Bueno, primero que nada, ¿que es lo siguiente que sucederá?
La primera industria tendrá un gran volumen, numerosos jugadores.
Justo la semana pasada se anunció otra nueva compañía.
Será de vuelo sub-orbital y la razón de que sea sub-orbital
es que no hay soluciones para tener la seguridad adecuada
para llevar al público general en órbita. Los gobiernos han estado haciendo esto -
Tres gobiernos a lo largo de 45 años,
y aún así, el 4 por ciento de las personas que han salido de la atmósfera han muerto.
Eso es... No querrían dirigir un negocio con ese tipo de historial de seguridad.
Será de gran volumen, pensamos que 100,000 personas estarán volando para el 2020.
No puedo decirles cuando empezará
porque no quiero que mi competencia conozca mis planes
Pero una vez que empiece, encontraremos soluciones.
y poco despues, verán hoteles en órbita.
y eso cosa sencilla de lograr, que es un giro alrededor de la Luna.
para que tengan un vista magnifica, y eso será genial.
Ya que la luna no tiene atmósfera --
puedes hacer órbitas elípticas y pasarla a 10 pies (3 metros) de distancia si así lo quieres.
Oh, esto va a ser tan divertido.
(risas)
OK. Mis críticos dicen, "Hey, Rutan está gastando
mucho del dinero de estos multimillonarios para paseos para multimillonarios.
¿Qué es esto? Esto no es un sistema de transporte, es solo diversión."
Y antes me molestaba eso, pero luego me puse a pensar,
bueno, esperen un minuto. Yo compré mi primer ordenador Apple en 1978
y la compré porque podía decir, "tengo un ordenador en mi casa y tú no."
- ¿Para qué la usas? - Vente. Tiene Frogger." Vale.
(risas)
No hablamos de los ordenadores de los bancos o de la compañia Lockheed.
el ordenador doméstico sólo era para jugar.
Durante toda una decada, era para divertirse - ni siquiera sabíamos para qué era útil.
Pero sucedió que teniamos esta industria grande
con un gran desarrollo, grandes mejoras, mas capacidad y demás,
y estaban llegando a muchos hogares, y el momento de una nueva invención llegó.
Y el inventor está en este auditorio.
Al Gore inventó Internet y es por eso que,
eso -- algo que usamos durante todo un año -- perdón,
durante toda una década para divertirnos, se convirtió en todo -- nuestro comercio, nuestra investigación,
nuestra comunicación y, si dejamos a la gente de Google
que piensen durante un par de fines de semana más, podemos agregar otra docena más de cosas en la lista.
Y no va a pasar mucho tiempo antes de que no podamos convencer a los niños
de que no siempre tuvimos ordenadores en nuestras casas.
Así que, "sólo por diversion" es una buena razón.
Ok, quiero mostrarles un diagrama,
pero en él está mi predicción acerca de lo que va a pasar.
Lo cual me lleva a otro punto, aquí mismo.
Hay un grupo de personas que ha salido adelante
y no los conocemos a todos, pero los que han salido adelante
fueron inspirados cuando eran niños, en ese pequeño lapso entre los 3 y 15 años de edad,
cuando nosotros orbitamos la tierra y fuimos a la luna aquí,
justo en este periodo de tiempo.
Paul Allen, Elan Musk, Richard Branson, Jeff Bezos, la familia Ansari.
quienes ahora están financiando los proyectos sub-orbitales rusos.
Bob Bigelow, una estación espacial privada y Carmack.
Estas personas están cogiendo su dinero e invirtiéndolo en un campo interesante,
y yo creo que es mejor que lo inviertan en
crear un nuevo teléfono móvil o algo asi -- pero lo están invirtiendo en una área no muy segura
y eso nos llevara a este tipo de capacidad
y nos llevará al próximo nivel
que nos permitirá explorar. Y pienso que eventualmente,
nos permitirá colonizar otros planetas y evitar que nos extingamos.
Ellos fueron inspirados por un gran progreso. Pero miren el progreso que hubo despues de eso.
Hay un par de ejemplos aquí.
Los aviones militares llegaron a su máxima capacidad,
con el SR71 Blackbird. Cumplió con su tiempo útil hasta que se oxidó.
y lo sacaron de servicio. El Concorde duplicó la velocidad de los vuelos comerciales.
Duró todo su tiempo de vida útil sin competencia.
y fue sacado de servicio. Y ahora estamos atascados aquí
con la misma capacidad en aviones militares
y líneas aéreas comerciales que la que teníamos al final de los 50.
Pero hay algo allá afuera que va a inspirar a los jovenes de ahora.
Y estoy hablando sobre si tienes un bebé ahora,
o un niño de 10 años ahora.
Allá afuera hay algo realmente interesante a punto de suceder.
Relativamente pronto, podrás comprar un ticket
y volar más alto, más rapido que el avión militar de mejores prestaciones.
Eso no había ocurrido antes.
La razón de que nos hayamos quedado atascados en este nivel de prestaciones
es que ahora, bueno, ya saben, pueden ganar la guerra en 12 minutos,
para qué necesitas algo mejor?
Pero creo que cuando ustedes empiecen a comprar billetes y a volar
en vuelos suborbitales al espacio, muy pronto -- esperen un segundo,
lo que pasará es que habrá aviones militares
con capacidad de vuelo sub-orbital y creo que será muy pronto.
Pero lo interesante es que las personas (área comercial) irán primero.
Ok, yo anhelo una nueva carrera espacial capitalista, llamemosle así.
Recuerden que la carrera espacial de los 60 fue por orgullo nacional,
ya que nos ganaron los primeros dos logros.
No los perdimos por falta de tecnología. El hecho de que teníamos el equipo
para poner algo en órbita cuando dejamos que Von Braun lo volara,
nos permite argumentar que no fué una derrota tecnológica.
El Sputnik tampoco fue una derrota tecnológica, pero fue una derrota de orgullo.
América -- el mundo ya no vió a América como el líder en tecnología,
y eso fué una impresión muy fuerte.
y semanas despues de Gagarín mandamos a Alan Shepherd,
no meses o décadas, o lo que sea. Así que teníamos la capacidad.
Pero América perdió. Nosotros perdimos. Y debido a eso, hicimos un gran salto para recuperarnos.
Bueno, lo interesante aquí es que hemos vuelto a perder.
ante los rusos con las primeros logros.
En América no puedes comprar un billete comercial para volar al espacio.
No se puede. En Rusia sí lo puedes comprar.
Puedes volar con equipo ruso. Está disponible.
porque el programa espacial ruso pasa hambre,
y para ellos es bueno obtener 20 millones aquí y allá a cambio de un asiento.
Es comercial. Se puede definir como turismo espacial. Ellos tambien ofrecen
un viaje para dar la vuelta alrededor de la Luna, como lo hizo Apollo 8.
por 100 millones de dolares -- hey, yo puedo ir a la Luna!
Pero, ya saben, ¿quién hubiera pensado allá en los 60.
cuando la carrera espacial estaba en marcha,
que el primer vuelo comercial-capitalista
donde se podría comprar un billete a la Luna sería con equipo ruso?
¿y hubieras pensado, hubieran pensado los rusos,
que cuando finalmente llegaran a la Luna, usando su equipo,
que los tripulantes no serían rusos? ¿ Seguramente sea un japonés,
o un multimillonario americano? Bueno, es extraño, realmente lo es.
De cualquier forma, creo que es el momento de volverles a ganar.
Creo que veremos una industria exitosa, muy exitosa,
de vuelos espaciales privados. Si somos los primeros o no, no importa.
Los rusos de hecho volaron un vuelo supersónico comercial antes del Concorde.
Y volaron un par de vuelos de carga y lo sacaron de servicio.
Creo que podemos ver el mismo patrón
en los viajes comerciales.
Ok, hablemos un poco acerca del desarrollo de vuelos comerciales para humanos.
Esto aqui dice que que hay 5 veces más
de lo que la NASA está haciendo para el 2020. Quiero decirles de una vez
hay entre 1500 millones y 1700 millones de dolares
invertidos en vuelos espaciales privados que no vienen del gobierno;
listos, alrededor del mundo. Lo pueden leer -- si lo buscan en Google,
encontrarán mencionada solo la mitad de esa cantidad, pero hay el doble
que ya está pactada, no se ha gastado todavía, pero está pactada
y planeada para los proximos años. Hey, eso es una gran cantidad.
Y predigo, que, aun con lo provechosa que será esta industria --
y realmente es provechosa cuando estás haciendo volar a cada persona por 200,000 dólares.
con algo que puedes operar con una décima parte de ese coste,
o menos, -- esto realmente será provechoso.
Predigo también, que la inversión que llegará
será alrededor de la mitad de lo que están pagando los contribuyentes americanos,
en los vuelos tripulados de la NASA.
Y cada dólar que vaya a parar a esto se gastará de forma más eficiente
con un factor de 10 o 15. Y eso significa que, antes de que nos demos cuenta,
el progreso del vuelo espacial tripulado, sin dinero del gobierno,
estará unas 5 veces más adelantado
que lo que la NASA dedica al vuelo espacial tripulado.
Y eso se debe a nosotros. La industria privada.
Nunca se debe depender del gobierno para hacer este tipo de cosas --
y lo hemos hecho por mucho tiempo. La NACA, antes de la NASA,
nunca desarrolló un avión y nunca tuvo una aerolínea.
Pero NASA está desarrollando el avión espacial, siempre lo ha hecho,
y tiene la única aerolínea espacial, OK. Pero no la hemos usado
porque le tenemos miedo. Pero empezando en Junio del 2004
cuando demostré que un pequeño grupo lo puede lograr,
que puede empezar, todo cambió despues de ese momento.
OK, muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)